FOLLOW @LAKERSCOMMUNITY ON
TWITTER, INSTAGRAM AND FACEBOOK
AS THEY STRIVE TO BE CHAMPS IN
THE COMMUNITY.
JAZZ WILL GET A COUPLE IN A ROW
AT HOME AFTER THIS ONE.
AFTER TONIGHT, NINE OUT OF 13 AT
HOME.
THIS ONE IS KNOCKED AROUND,
TAKEN BY RUSS.
GOOD REBOUND BY THE LAKERS.
RUSS ALL THE WAY.
COUNT IT!
STU: AND ONE.
BILL: COUNT IT AND ONE FOR
RUSSELL WESTBROOK.
STU: DID YOU HEAR ME HOLLERING
STOP?
YOU WANT TO USE THE CLOCK, BUT
RUSS SAID I HAVE A LANE, I WILL
ATTACK THE BASKET.
HE TAKES IT THE DISTANCE, GETS
THE FOUL AND ONE.
HE'S AT THE LINE FOR A POSSIBLE
THREE-POINT PLAY.
WHAT A SEQUENCE BY THE LAKERS.
BILL: THEY'RE UP SEVEN WITH 40
SECONDS TO PLAY.
RUSS FREE-THROWING TONIGHT, HE'S
MADE HIS ONLY ATTEMPT.
RUSS WITH A DOZEN TO GO ALONG
WITH SEVEN REBOUNDS AND THREE
ASSISTS.
HE GOES THE DISTANCE.
WE'VE GOT A TIMEOUT.
STU: WOW.
WHAT A SEQUENCE IN THE LAST 25,